قال مراسل الجزيره ان السلطات الاوكرانيه
اعلنت حاله اتاهب الجوي في العاصمه كياف
ومقاطعات خيرسون وميكولايف واوديسه
وزابولوجيا
ان المدينه تعرضت للقصب المدفعيه وقذائف
الهاون نحو احدى وسبعين مره ليلى الماضيه
قتل فيها 13 مدنيا واصيب العشرات ومن
جانبها
بمقتل ثلاثه من افراد اجهزه الطوارئ اثناء
ازاله الغنم في منطقه
كما اتهمت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه القوات
الروسيه بشني اكثر من 90 هجوم صاروخيا على
مقاطعه عده في البلاد وقالت الهيئه ان
الروسي
كثافهم شرقا باتجاه ضخمود ولمان وارضيكا
بينما يحاول الجيش الاوكراني صدام الهجمات
الروسيه في اكثر من جبهه لا سيما كوبيان
صاروخيه وجويه واكثر من 90 هجوما من منصات
اطلاق صواريخ متعدده على اهداف مدنيه في
خير صور ما اسفر عن مقتل مدنيين العدو
يركز جهوده على القيام باعمال هجوميه في
اتجاهات الايمان وباخ موت وافديف كما صدق
قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه هجمات المحتلين في
مناطق عده